[Music]
every manager at our company has a
college degree the only thing stopping
you is you
[Music]
do you ever look at your life wonder how
you got there if you made different
choices would you be happy
Martha got his MBA from Duke he's the
best man for the job
no sir I am I just wish we lived in a
world where street smarts equal book
smarts school oh the educated people and
their fancy houses name their kids after
fruit and climb Kilimanjaro so lady
Caulfield something about a job
interview oh my god franklin and clark a
resume interests me Wharton Business
School I'm sorry Mike
and of course you have got to see her
Facebook page my facebook page Obama I
gave you a completely new idea you said
you wanted to be fancy so I just like
Cinderella's your ass well I got you in
the door you got the job baby who's the
champ let's go who's the chick on the
tail you're the you're the champ
it's not easy getting a job for a woman
your age Oh
watch me I'm a bi
[Music]
oh okay we need to wear anything other
than that you look like mrs. Doubtfire
wow this is my office
buddy cards I'm gonna take these walk
again don't you dare I'm gonna take
these coasters you're gonna come clean
right Maya
these are my friends from Norton Warren
waited some time in the Peace Corps
together we save whales okay she's a
Facebook thing with we you really are
I feel II admire you but kind of who I
want to be when I grow up
[Applause]
you own that every dollar we're looking
at the new Chinese distributor the only
employee we have who speaks mana zone
for me I got an idea our cats
veterinarian speaks manner we would love
to schedule a tour for you but we have
to wait for the deal to be closed what
you're the tough feet chances that Oh
peppermint Sierra yo G suddenly gone mom
she
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you